(Door opening)
Katharine Gun?
What were you employed to do?
I translated signals intelligence and I reported anything of interest to my clients.
You're a spy.
Did your capacity fail?
The Americans want us to help them get a UN resolution for war.
So you work for the British government?
No.
No?
This proposed war is historically unfortunate.
I work for the British people.
I do not gather intelligence so that the government can lie to the British people.
Intelligence may be being manipulated to take this country to war.
I could get you a copy.
You're asking me to put in to a breach of the Official Secrets Act.
Phone call that treason.
Someone has betrayed their government and their country.
You might need our help.
If we you do not go public,
we would be conceding that no one can ever tell the people when their government is lying.
Your marriage will be interrogated.
My husband had absolutely nothing to do with this.
He's a Muslim.
I'm sorry?
You chose loyalty to your country over loyalty to your government.
Your marriage and yourself, I think that speaks rather highly of you.
Katharine Louisa Gun, you're charged with an offense
at the Official Secrets Act.
Do you want to risk it all?
How do you plead?